staff at one of russia's most prominent
independent television stations have
resigned live on air
no to war was the final statement made
on rain tv the channel's suspending
operations after being threatened with
closure by authorities in its last
seconds on the air the channel broadcast
the swan lake ballet performance it was
often played on loop by soviet tv and
radio either at times of political
crisis or after the death of a leader
let's go to dos jabari who's standing by
in moscow dosa so rain tv shut itself
down how many other news networks are
left able to challenge the kremlin
narrative
well there are not any left the
russian censorship bodies have said that
many of them have been shut down over
the past two weeks since the start of
the
russian invasion in ukraine
and of course this was one of the only
tv independent tv channels i was
operating and last week tv reign
received a noted notice as well as
other local media channels and news
outlets in the country warning them not
to use certain language when describing
the
invasion that was ongoing in ukraine
they had to
stay away from words such as invasion
and war and describe it as a military a
special military operation of course
this channel was taken off air last week
and then they were broadcasting on
youtube online and then
on wednesday evening
the
on thursday evening rather the um
uh founders of the channel decided that
it was no longer possible uh for them to
continue their work and that they were
going to be shut down eventually so on
the last few minutes of broadcast they
decided to
show the ballet of swan lake
tchaikovsky's swan lake the russian
composer who debuted his valet in moscow
in 1877 and this is a nod to russian
history because this ballet of swan lake
was shown on state tv during the 80s
when leaders passed away as well as
during the coup uh or
1991 which led to
the end of the soviet union so it is
very well known by the public here as a
sign of
instability when they see that ballet on
air and this tv channel which was
founded in 2010
chose to leave um their broadcast the
last broadcast with this ballet as a
sign of possibly
darker days ahead for the
media in this country very poignant uh
dorsa
parliament has also
voted or is voting on how to treat those
who break its rules around what can
and can't be said in the media
yes this was a
bill that was just passed in the lower
house of parliament known as the duma
and it was voted on by
mps in session and it passed unanimously
with 401 votes and it is a law that
will
see people
from the media being heavily fined as
well as facing jail terms of up to 15
years
if they use language that is
detrimental to
the russian military and the defense
forces according to the language that is
in this bill it is now illegal to
publicly discredit the use of
the armed forces and that for the spread
of false information and they about the
country's armed forces is now illegal
and you cannot um disseminate fake
information about russia's armed forces
so the censorship getting very much
stronger and now it will become law that
is very very dangerous i think for not
only uh russian independent media which
ceases to exist at this point
and also foreign media which of many of
them have now their websites of foreign
media been blocked in the country
because they are being accused of
spreading false information about the
ongoing invasion in ukraine
all right dost dubai there for us in
moscow thank you